[Music]
so many believed that the digital realm
would be a place for hope and idealism
but as billion-dollar fines from the EU
testify the digital Giants have used
their monopoly power to generate ever
greater profits and squeeze out
competitors while at the same time
paying little or no tax does the
dominance of these new corporations
necessarily make them dangerous can we
break them up or regulate them to end
their monopoly or with plans for new
taxes failing is it already too late for
national governments to take control to
my left we've got Philip blond he is a
political philosopher anglican
theologian and his director of the race
pública think-tank moving to our rights
we have Anatole Colette ski he's an
economist and writer born in the Soviet
Union Anatole learned his trade at
Cambridge and Harvard he has since been
the times this economic editor and now
works as a columnist for Reuters and
last but definitely not least we have
Nicky Morgan she's Conservative MP and
former lawyer so the big question
reminds us all is does the dominance of
the digital giants necessarily make them
dangerous you have three minutes
undoubtedly it does one of the great
tragedies of the conservative ascendancy
over the past years in the UK is that we
haven't rethought competition law and
for a supposedly free-market party we
have presided over the most astonishing
market concentrations that we've
arguably ever witnessed it's far greater
than the Edwardian period for instance
and as a result we've introduced not
just oligopolies but monopolies and
tragically we don't recognize them as
such and part of that is because our
competition law is out of date and
actually runs on a pro monopoly model so
we have what's called consumer welfare
as the ultimate standard for assessing
market concentration but the point is is
if we have us one business that does
everything for
everyone always think Amazon's ambitions
that will deliver consumer welfare
because it has the economies of scale it
can deliver you things far cheaper than
anybody else and that's been our
competition law so consequently we've
let mergers through we've we've
celebrated what we should decry and we
are creating a new form of feudalism now
if you cast your mind back to the Middle
Ages as I know many of you do in the
Middle Ages the feudal serf relationship
was quite interesting serfs could
actually make a surplus they would work
the land and once they had paid the rent
to the Lord that surplus belonged to
them the modern feudalism that we are
now looking at is there was no surplus
at all for any workers that all the
returns from the undoubted innovations
technology brings goes to the owners of
that tech and they are creating a world
in which there is no asset for you and
because there is no asset or no
ownership for you because all of our
businesses are being put out of business
by the new monopolies there is no
conservative route to self emancipation
I believe that properly figured the
market economy will empower people
through ownership through business
ownership will be an agent of
redistribution that is now fanciful in
the face of the new monopolies and the
new politics in my view of the
emancipatory right if I can use that
conjunction has to be the restoration of
market power not just to consumers but
to the producers who are denied access
to the market and who are forever going
to be trapped in the new Ron ta economy
and will never own thank you
thank you very much Nichkhun over to you
well thank you very much and thank you
to the organizers opportunity to be here
to today and you mentioned I'm a a
lawyer so I shall do what lawyers always
do which is go back to definitions and
let's think what we mean by dangerous
what we mean by dangerous is something
that causes harm or has adverse
consequences now I'm not going to go in
quite the historical tour that Phillip
has just just done but I absolutely
agree with so much of what he has said
and last week in Parliament I'm part of
a group of conservative MPs who
relaunched one nation ISM we set out a
declaration of values and one things we
put in there about markets in the
economy was the need to break monopolies
and to enhance competition and I think
that the tech giants absolutely should
be front and center in terms of the way
that the government of the day my party
is thinking about this this issue and
there's a few things that really concern
me both as a former minister a chair of
the Treasury select committee but also
as a constituency member of parliament
the first undoubtedly is the financial
power of our tech giants just the size
of them and I was reading some this
morning that said Amazon the size of
Amazon the turnover is greater than the
size of example of the Portuguese
economy now you might not think the
Portuguese economy is one of those great
wonders of the world but when you've got
one company whose economy will Turner is
bigger than a country's and it becomes
harder and harder we're going to come
onto this to talk too about governments
being able to regulate and to to tackle
the next thing as undoubtedly the cyber
risks you know data is the new natural
resource and actually the risks whether
it's Cambridge analytic are the misuse
of data or the illegal harvesting of
data and the use of our data I don't
think we are nearly protective enough
about the data that we give to these
tech giants that they use for their own
commercial benefits you know a couple of
years ago Parliament email and many
other organizations emails have been
hacked and brought down now actually as
my colleague just Philip so wonderfully
said
whoever it was wanted to deal with our
constituency emails our potholes our
benefit queries and everything else for
a week fine they didn't want to do that
but the point is actually to bring down
large organizations including our
Parliament emails just shows the the
cyber risks that are out there and that
again are our tech giant's showing the
responsibility that they should do
there's a social power issue as well
when I was education secretary s but a
lot of my time thinking about well being
about mental health about character of
young people who want to develop if
we're having to give young people not
just young but often older but young
people lessons in how to deal with the
issues around social media the fact that
actually your friends online are not
necessarily friends in real life they're
not people who actually have their best
your best interests at heart then that
tells me something has gone wrong with
the tech that we are all using let alone
the fact we've also given a platform
these organizations are they are
publishers now that their platforms for
often illegal and extremely harmful
activity witnessed the recent
Christchurch killings where the killer
decided to broadcast live what he was
doing on Facebook and it took Facebook
far far too long which should me up
there in the first place but far far too
long to get it down as it was being
broadcast and then finally I think will
come on to the effects on democracy now
we see elections now consistently
undermined by what's going on online in
the UK obviously we've had the recent
online harms white paper we have the
Furman Review as well I think the area
of self-regulation is very much over but
there's no doubt that governments are
playing catch-up on this issue and
finally I think we just need to think
about this is reminiscent of the
financial crisis there was a big debate
about financial regulations or
light-touch self regulation and
governments caught up too late to the
dangers of that and we saw a financial
and banking crisis that we are still
seeing the effects of over 10 years
later but we shouldn't it's not all doom
and gloom they're all there are some
advantages there are some ways of
tackling we can talk perhaps about the
GDP our from the EU and some of the
regulations the Margaery
- Vesta Varga for example is taking a
relation to tackling competition but
there are probably in this audience and
elsewhere many startups charities and
others who benefit enormously from the
power of online the power to use the
Amazon Marketplace the power to
publicize through Facebook so the
questions how do you harness the
potential for good whilst also being
very realistic about the ability and the
desire to tackle the harms thanks so
much
Anatole well I agree with a lot of
pretty much everything we've just heard
from from the other two speakers with a
slight exception of a couple of points
that Philip made but I think we should
be careful not to overstate the case for
example I think the title of this talk
the new mafia I think is it gives an
false impression of the kind of danger
that society faces from these
organizations and also if we want to
find something constructive and positive
to do in response I think it's important
to distinguish between a number of
actual and potential harms all of which
require rather different responses from
Society for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at III TV
you